Le 28 juin 1914, l'assassinat brutal
de l'héritier de l'Empire austro-hongrois
par un jeune Bosniaque
nationaliste et romantique
déchaîne des forces qui plongent
le monde dans un holocauste inconcevable
créé par les hommes.
La Première Guerre
mondiale, la Grande Guerre.
En l'espace de quelques semaines,
les armées des puissances
impériales européennes se mobilisent,
courant au-devant d'un
affrontement entraînant le monde entier
dans un tourbillon mortel.
Un conflit impitoyable
qui, en quatre ans seulement,
fait 9 millions de morts
sur les champs de bataille,
cause d'innombrables souffrances
et des désolations indescriptibles
et transforme complètement
la face du monde et des conflits.
Mais le meurtre sordide
de l'archiduc Ferdinand et de son épouse
ne fait que raviver
les braises de soupçons,
de conflits et de rivalités impériales
qui couvent en Europe
depuis des décennies.
Au centre de ce fairmont
se trouve l'ambition allemande,
inspirée par le rusé maître
diplomate Otto Von Bismarck,
le chancelier de fer.
35 États allemands disparates
fusionnent en une seule entité
et le succès remporté
dans la guerre franco prussienne de 1870
donne à la jeune
Allemagne une position assurée
en tant que force militaire européenne.
Les trois décennies suivantes
sont témoins de progrès gigantesques
dans le domaine de
l'industrialisation, de la technologie,
de l'éducation et du commerce extérieur.
Sa population augmente de
20 millions tandis que celle de la France,
son ennemi de longue date, décline.
En 1900, une Allemagne
forte et sûre d'elle se sent prête
à entrer dans le club impérial,
à s'intégrer sur la scène mondiale,
scène que les autres
puissances peuvent juger encombrée.
Les puissances ont lieu de s'inquiéter
lorsque l'empereur Guillaume II
oblige Bismarck à démissionner.
Bismarck, dont la diplomatie
vise simplement la défense
et la sécurité du Reich naissant.
Travailleur et intelligent,
mais aussi ambitieux et impulsif,
le nouvel empereur endosse
le manteau de seigneur de guerre
de la caste prussienne
militaire étrangère à la diplomatie,
imbue des chimères
de la puissance germanique.
Cependant,
il existe davantage de similitudes
que de différences parmi
les puissances et leur classe dirigeante,
des tas de choses qui auraient dû opposer
un rempart à toute idée de conflit.
Un cousinage d'empereur
se trouve renforcé par une élite politique
et militaire exclusive,
toute aussi à l'aise
dans les palais somptueux que
dans les cercles et les salons de Berlin,
Vienne, Petrograd, Londres ou Paris.
Contrastant avec l'existence brillante
et gaie de cette minorité dirigeante
et de son entourage
de dilettantes riches et privilégiés,
s'oppose la vie morne
et appauvrie de la majorité
de la masse populaire,
des paysans des vastes étendues rurales
de l'empire des Romanov,
dont les conditions de vie ont peu changé,
jusqu'à la classe ouvrière des villes,
menant une existence
misérable dans des taudis hérités
de la révolution industrielle.
Mais les masses ne sont plus
les esclaves d'un féodalisme rigide.
L'industrialisation
et l'éducation du XIXᵉ siècle
et les diverses
concessions à la démocratie
ont créé un prolétariat industriel
qui sait exprimer son mécontentement,
impatient de réparer les
injustices de l'état actuel des choses.
Le spectre du socialisme
hante les salons des riches.
De profondes divisions nationales
harcèlent aussi les chefs des empires.
L'Empereur François Joseph
d'Autriche exerce une autorité fragile
sur un empire millénaire
composé de 17 nationalités disparates.
Teutons, Slaves,
Croates, Serbes, Tchèques, Magyars.
La Grande-Bretagne fait
face à des insurrections inspirées
par la campagne
pour l'autonomie de l'Irlande.
Les dynasties régnantes de l'Europe,
entravées par leurs difficultés internes,
politiques et sociales,
ne semble guère encline
à faire la guerre à leurs cousins.
Cependant la course
aux armements s'intensifie
et le mouvement vers la guerre continue.
Personne ne semble
vouloir la guerre en 1914.
La Russie se remet encore de l'échec
de la guerre russo-japonaise de 1904.
La France réarme
alors qu'elle vient d'élire
un gouvernement pacifiste et
semble en meilleur terme avec l'Allemagne.
L'Autriche-Hongrie
fait face à ses propres problèmes
causés par les nationalistes
combattants dans les Balkans.
La Grande-Bretagne insouciante se contente
de maintenir l'ordre dans son empire.
En Allemagne, les industriels sont sûrs
qu'elle deviendra
une grande puissance en Europe
uniquement par la vigueur de son économie.
Les grandes puissances
ont comme atout de dissuasion
des armées ou des marines puissantes,
et elles nouent des alliances
pour empêcher toute agression éventuelle.
Les grandes puissances ont des problèmes
à l'intérieur de leurs frontières.
Mais à qui pourrait
profiter un conflit majeur?
Cependant, en août 1914, le gigantesque
jeu d'échecs diplomatique se détériore.
Toutes les garanties
et tous les équilibres
préservant la paix
en Europe s'effondrent,
et les alliances de
l'ancienne diplomatie sont invoquées.
L'Allemagne avec l'Autriche-Hongrie
et l'entente cordiale entre la Russie,
la France et la Grande-Bretagne.
Peu de doute que le Kaiser représente
la plus grande menace pour la paix.
En décembre 1912, il réunit un conseil
de guerre de l'élite militaire allemande
en butte aux diplomates.
La nation allemande
commence à être reconnue
par sa puissance militaire et impériale.
En 1900, l'amiral Von Tirpitz
prépare un plan de 15 ans
exposant un vaste
programme de construction navale.
Son objectif marquant
est de doter l'Empire allemand d'une arme
qui peut arracher à la Grande-Bretagne
sa juste part de puissance coloniale.
En 1914, le canal de Kiel
est élargi pour permettre
aux nouveaux grands cuirassés
de passer de la Baltique à la mer du Nord.
En 1914, l'Allemagne
possède une armée de terre
remarquablement bien entraînée
et commandée par un corps d'officiers
formés dans la plus
pure tradition prussienne.
Le comte Alfred von Schlieffen
donne au Reich un plan de guerre
sans pareil
dans le cas où celle-ci serait déclarée.
L'Allemagne est enfin prête,
sinon impatiente de se battre.
Dans son essence,
le plan Schlieffen est simple.
Quatre armées allemandes jouerait un rôle
défensif le long de leur propre frontière.
Les trois autres grandes armées
écraserait la Belgique en une gigantesque
poussée en arc de cercle
tout en contournant les Français.
L'élément de rapidité et de surprise,
balayeraient les Français du terrain,
les armées allemandes se retourneraient,
renforçant leur action de retenue
à l'Est contre les Russes,
qui seraient longs à se mobiliser.
Ce plan apporterait une solution à la
crainte d'une guerre sur deux fronts.
Le plan Schlieffen
va dépendre littéralement
de la ponctualité
du réseau ferroviaire allemand.
Le train de 9h45 de Berlin à Bruxelles
est toujours le Berlin-Bruxelles.
Seule la cargaison a sinistrement changée.
À Sarajevo, la longue attente se termine
et le boulet de la guerre en Europe
sillonne comme une traînée de poudre,
du centre de la tempête balkanique
vers l'extérieur.
Les ultimatums,
les menaces et les contre menaces
s'échangent à travers l'Europe.
Mais les dés sont jetés,
les ambitions vaines, les obligations,
la naïve pression publique ou
la peur poussent les grandes puissances
au combat les unes après les autres.
Des millions de troupes sont
conduites vers les zones de combat,
sous les cris perçants de
"À Berlin ! À Paris !"
Atteindre la tête de ligne est une chose.
Transporter de nombreuses armées
jusqu'au front en est une autre.
Un fantassin ne va pas plus vite
en 1914 qu'un siècle auparavant lors
de la confrontation de Waterloo.
Les opérations logistiques
de transport et de ravitaillement
des grandes armées de terre
avec leur artillerie lourde
et leurs armes sont impressionnantes.
Le déplacement d'une division de
12 000 hommes avec leurs chevaux,
leurs magasins et
leurs équipements demande 1000 wagons.
En tête de ligne commence une longue
et pénible marche dans la boue
pour atteindre le front.
Une fois déchargé d'un train,
une division occupe 25 kilomètres de route
et prend 5 heures à passer une borne.
La première armée allemande
compte à elle seule 320 000 hommes.
Tandis que l'Allemagne représente
le mobile principal de l'action,
c'est le système des alliances
qui doit déterminer l'échelle du conflit.
Les grandes armées constituées pour
assurer la sécurité et préserver la paix,
assument une fois engagées,
un dynamisme propre et sans retenue.
Comme attiré
par un aimant vers l'Alsace-Lorraine,
le plan français envoie les
troupes au Nord en direction du Rhin
faisant le jeu des Allemands.
Le 4 août 1914, ne tenant aucun
compte de la neutralité de la Belgique,
les formidables armées allemandes
déferlant au-delà de leurs frontières.
Le cauchemar de la Première
Guerre mondiale a commencé.
L'illusion que le conflit n'est qu'une
guerre de mouvement est vite dissipée,
tandis que l'avance
rapide des armées allemandes
s'épuise à l'approche de la Marne.
Certaines unités de la
première armée de Von Kluck diminuées
et épuisées sur
la lisière de l'arc de cercle,
couvrent une distance
moyenne de 40 kilomètres par jour.
Même si les allemands gagnent
la bataille de la Marne,
ils ne peuvent aller plus loin.
Leurs lignes de
communication sont distancées,
leurs lignes
d'approvisionnement s'épuisent.
Ces armées modernes
ne peuvent vivre des ressources du pays.
Le ressort allemand est distendu.
Le plan de Schlieffen a échoué.
La résistance courageuse
de la brave petite Belgique
à la forteresse de Liège
retarde la poussée allemande
pendant une période
cruciale de onze jours,
permettant ainsi aux
forces alliées de s'organiser.
À l'Est le début de la
guerre se montre défavorable
aux puissances d'Europe centrale,
repoussées avec mépris de la Serbie,
avec une aisance extrême par
certains des meilleurs guerriers du monde,
vaincus à Gumbinnen par
des hordes de Russes en haillons,
mais néanmoins irrésistibles
et forcés d'évacuer la Galice.
Tous ces échecs sont
compensés par la bataille tactique
et brillante de Tannenberg,
où les Allemands abattent une armée russe
numériquement supérieure
et font 100 000 prisonniers.
Cette bataille, la plus grande victoire
de la guerre met en évidence deux hommes
qui vont diriger
l'effort de guerre de l'Allemagne.
Paul Von Hindenburg,
un soldat de carrière
de 66 ans rappelé de sa retraite,
et en parallèle,
le brillant stratège Erich Ludendorff.
A mesure que les manœuvres
d'encerclement des premiers mois
sur le front de l'Ouest
sont parés et arrêtés,
l'échec de la course vers
la mer se profile, ils s'épuisent,
la guerre de mouvement ralentit,
et les deux armées se
retranchent de la Suisse jusqu'à la mer.
A l'Est, un front plus fluide se
dessine alors que les armées désorientées,
renoncent à se retrouver dans les espaces
vides, au-delà des têtes de lignes.
Dans le no man's land, entre les lignes,
des paysans cultivent toujours la terre.
Une impasse lorsque
l'hiver s'installe sur les deux fronts.
La guerre ne sera pas finie à Noël.
Le coup des opérations
militaires de 1914 est stupéfiant.
Les morts et les blessés
se comptent déjà par millions,
et le résultat que les armées
peuvent retirer de ce carnage
se résument à une impasse.
Impasse mortelle qui durera des années.
Les espérances se heurtent à la
dure réalité que de millions de réfugiés
portant leurs pathétiques
ballots, fuyant la Belgique occupée
sous le regard hébété d'officiers
de cavalerie, d'opéra-comique,
avec leurs plumes et fanions, leurs épées,
leurs lances et leurs idées démodées,
inspectant les champs de bataille.
Ce n'est pas la glorieuse et rapide
guerre à laquelle ils s'attendaient.
Chacune des nations
combattantes est saisie par la folie
du mois d'octobre 1914,
quand les hommes répondent partout
à l'appel aux armes
en un fervent élan patriotique.
En Grande-Bretagne,
des recrues de tous les âges
arrivent en nombre pour s'enrôler.
Ce n'est pas une guerre de paysans,
ni une guerre de soldats de carrière.
Des classes d'université entières,
tous les employés d'un même travail,
des villes et des villages entiers s'en
vont à la guerre en bataillons de copains.
Les gens avec qui ils ont vécu
deviennent les gens avec qui ils meurent.
Ainsi, les hommes de toute une ville
pouvaient être virtuellement anéantis
lors d'une grande bataille.
Ce ne doit pas être
le bref interlude glorieux de leur vie
où l'appel au devoir renferme
une promesse de grande aventure.
Le prestige de l'uniforme,
c'est aussi une pause
dans la monotonie
de l'existence et pour certains,
la première
assurance d'un salaire régulier.
Dans les pays
où la conscription est de règle,
l'ardeur de se joindre à
la bataille n'est pas moins forte.
L'Europe est aux prises
à une hystérie guerrière.
Dieu, semble-t-il,
est avec chacun, même avec le Kaiser.
Dieu a entendu le chant
et le cri des nations en bataille :
"God Save England"
et "God Save the King".
Dieu par-ci, Dieu par-là et Dieu partout !
"Mon Dieu !", dit alors Dieu.
"Que de travail pour nous."
En Grande-Bretagne, les rues, les salles
de concert et même les chaires d'église
réagissent à
l'engouement infectieux de cette passion
et de ce sentiment nationaliste.
Les membres de la famille royale décident
de changer leur nom germanique.
Saxe-Cobourg-Gotha devient Windsor.
Battenberg devient Mountbatten.
Mais il y a aussi
un sinistre aspect à ce zèle populaire,
une cruelle xénophobie.
La haine pour le Kaiser
Guillaume le gangster se mue en outrage,
et quiconque porte un nom qui
semble étranger est victime de la foule.
L'étranger devient alors l'ennemi.
Le rôle de la propagande en tant qu'arme
prend un intérêt et
une importance inconnus jusqu'ici.
Le développement de la presse populaire
prête aux responsables de la propagande
les moyens de véhiculer
leur message simplifié.
Un message à sensation chauviniste
et rarement fidèle à la réalité.
L'image de l'ennemi dépeint
tel un monstre est avidement absorbé
par un public assoiffé de batailles,
tandis que l'idée de guerre
héroïque et glorieuse est renforcée
par la présentation d'une vérité déformée
quand il s'agit des cruelles réalités.
Au niveau officiel,
on ordonne des internements
sur une grande échelle
des étrangers présumés.
La Grande-Bretagne
n'est pas seule à réagir ainsi.
Les ressortissants étrangers sont aussi
arrêtés en Allemagne et en Autriche.
Pourtant, l'appui pour
la guerre n'est pas universel.
Dans les villes, au départ des
troupes et dans les centres de recrutement
la ferveur est contagieuse.
Dans les vastes régions rurales de
l'Europe, dans l'apathie quasi générale,
on a une attitude
résignée face à la guerre.
La Grande-Bretagne,
protégée de l'invasion,
peut parler aisément d'une guerre juste,
alors qu'elle réagit
au destin de la petite Belgique.
Mais l'Europe continentale a déjà subi
les conséquences de conflits similaires.
Des hommes absents
pour la moisson, des foyers détruits,
de pitoyables colonnes de réfugiés.
La guerre qui se prolonge cause des
problèmes pour les hommes politiques.
En Grande-Bretagne en particulier,
l'économie doit être prête
pour assurer
des vivres aux soldats affamés.
Le recrutement continue laisse de graves
lacunes dans la main d'œuvre industrielle.
Le gouvernement se rend
compte trop tard qu'il a perdu
les précieux ouvriers
des mines et de sidérurgie
partis au front
dans la vague d'enthousiasme,
et il s'efforce en vain de les
rappeler avant qu'il ne soit trop tard.
Mais la majorité des brèches
sont comblés par des femmes
et finalement par des enfants.
Légalisation cynique
d'une pratique devenue habituelle
depuis longtemps
dans les familles très pauvres.
Tandis que les
suffragettes de la classe moyenne
saluent cet accroissement
comme un
acquis en faveur de l'émancipation,
la vérité est
connue de la classe ouvrière
et qu'il s'agit simplement
d'un travail supplémentaire.
On peut gagner plus
d'argent dans les usines de munitions
que comme domestiques
ou dans les filatures.
Les responsables
de la propagande tirent parti
de cette nouvelle armée nationale féminine
malgré les protestations et ressentiment
manifestés dans les lieux de travail
traditionnellement masculins
et les inquiétudes de danger moral
et d'abandon d'enfants.
Toute fascination disparaît bien vite,
les femmes s'apercevant
qu'elles assument deux emplois
et travaillent
durant un grand nombre d'heures.
La plupart des foyers ont au
moins un membre de famille à l'armée
et les augmentations de salaire
ne compensent pas l'inflation galopante.
Seuls les usuriers
amassent de l'argent grâce à la guerre.
Heureusement pour
les hommes politiques en Allemagne,
la trêve entre les classes tient bon
et le Kaiser peut prononcer
ces quelques mots avec gratitude
devant le Reichstag à majorité socialiste.
"Je ne vois pas de partis ici,
seulement des Allemands."
Dans cet esprit initial
de coopération et d'unité,
les mécanismes de la guerre
sont bien huilés et la guerre continue.
L'entrée en guerre
de la Grande-Bretagne et de sa marine
démontre que la guerre
européenne devient mondiale
alors que la guerre
se poursuit où l'Allemagne
ou ses alliés ont de l'influence.
La marine britannique
transporte des troupes à son gré
et la flotte allemande
est impuissante face à elle.
L'Empire britannique domine les mers.
L'entrée en guerre
du Japon le 23 août 1914
est une garantie
de cette suprématie écrasante
à laquelle les commandants allemands
réagissent avec
une prudence exagérée et continue.
La haute mer
n'est pas témoin de conflits importants.
Les grands cuirassés passent et repassent
pour assurer le blocus et contre-blocus.
Leur commandant, peu enclin
à risquer leur précieux fardeau.
Ces grands navires sont
superflus dans la course aux armements,
représentant
un gaspillage de technologies
et de matériaux démodés et extravagants,
face à la menace
silencieuse des sous-marins
qui émergent comme
seul espoir de l'Allemagne
de briser le blocus paralysant des alliés.
Une attaque sous-marine isolée a
un effet politique profond sur la guerre.
Le 17 mai 1915,
le sous-marin allemand U-20
torpille le paquebot
de la ligne Cunard Lusitania,
dans la dernière partie
de son voyage de New York à Liverpool.
1198 hommes, femmes
et enfants parmi les 2000 passagers,
y compris des Américains,
périssent dans le naufrage.
Alors que leurs corps sont
rejetés sur les plages de Kinsale,
le public réagit avec horreur,
particulièrement en Amérique, pays neutre.
Il fut révélé plus tard que le paquebot
transportait du matériel de guerre.
Mais le tort avait été fait.
Nation neutre
la plus puissante, les États-Unis,
est attirée
inexorablement vers la cause des alliés.
Le torpillage du
Lusitania n'est pas le seul signe
de l'aspect sinistre
et mortel de la guerre moderne.
Le sous-marin
n'est pas la seule arme du XXᵉ siècle
à dissiper les vestiges romantiques
de la contemplation de la guerre.
L'impasse où se trouve
le front de l'Ouest en 1915
est loin d'être en perte.
Pendant tout l'hiver,
le printemps et l'automne,
les combats sont continus,
meurtriers, onéreux, futiles.
Des deux côtés, on lance des offensives
mal coordonnées sur les lignes ennemies.
Neuve Chapelle, Loos, Artois,
Champagne,
Côte d'Aubers, Ypres, Festubert.
Les mortiers,
les obusiers et l'artillerie lourde
creuse ce paysage
qu'on ne peut oublier et qui reste
l'image surréaliste de la Grande Guerre.
Un terrain vague, saccagé, boue sanglant
couvert de corps mutilés des combattants.
Chaque soldat ne connaît
que sa propre guerre.
Le monde bizarre
du simple soldat n'est qu'un point
sur la scène monumentale
de la guerre, dans lequel il ressent
toute une gamme d'émotions,
depuis la peur paralysante
jusqu'à l'ennui abjecte.
Le long de ces
quelques centaines de mètres de front,
il vit avec sa nouvelle famille,
son propre escadron ou peloton,
la seule chose
qui ait un sens dans ce cauchemar
infesté de rats et de poux,
pénétrés de la puanteur envahissante
de corps et de pourriture.
Contrairement au
mythe qui persiste encore,
seul un quart du temps
s'est passé dans les tranchées.
Mais ce temps a
banni toute description pour l'éternité.
Pour le reste, s'il survit,
la vie est d'une monotonie prévisible.
Relevé seulement d'un
humour fataliste, légèrement insolent,
et des liens étroits de camaraderie.
Mais l'humour prend une nuance amère.
"Bonjour !", a dit le général rencontré la
semaine dernière en chemin vers le front.
"Maintenant, la plupart des soldats
qu'il saluait en souriant sont morts."
"Nous maudissons son état-major."
"Salauds incompétents."
Harry grommelait à Jack,
"Drôle d'original",
en marchant d'un pas lourd vers
Arras, fusils et équipements sur le dos.
Mais ils ont été fichus
tous deux par son plan d'attaque.
Les généraux sont tout aussi perplexes
et acculés par le monstre
effrayant qui est déchaîné.
Ils essaient désespérément
de lancer des forces géantes
depuis la salle des cartes loin du front,
en criant des ordres contradictoires
dans les téléphones de terrain
le long d'une chaîne
de commandement embrouillée.
Les communications sont épouvantables.
Un méli-mélo de messagers,
de pigeons voyageurs
et de fusées éclairantes,
les lignes téléphoniques
coupées par des tirs de barrage.
Une fois l'offensive décidée
les généraux ont peu
ou pas du tout
de contrôle sur le déroulement.
Les batailles deviennent des événements
confus dans le brouillard de la guerre.
Cependant, le phénomène
de solidarité nationale,
au milieu d'une saignée
et de souffrances effroyables tient bon,
malgré quelques faibles
manifestations de mécontentement.
L'opinion publique attisée par la
presse et une propagande à sensation
attribue les qualités
de demi-Dieu aux chefs militaires.
Hindenburg, Kitchener
et Joffre, personnifient la volonté
de remporter la victoire pour leur pays.
Tout citoyen loyal
est censé avoir une foi aveugle
en ces grands guerriers, qui perdent pied
comme ils tâtonnent à la
recherche de l'insaisissable victoire
qui les sortira du cauchemar.
Comme les fragiles biplans apparaissent
au-dessus de la fumée de la bataille,
une autre dimension
est ajoutée à la guerre,
embryon qui conduit seulement 30 ans
après aux horreurs de Hiroshima :
la guerre aérienne.
La puissance aérienne en est à ses débuts.
L'avion n'est qu'un
simple outil de reconnaissance,
de mitraillage au sol
primitif et de perturbation mineure
des mouvements de troupes ennemies
et de leur ligne de ravitaillement.
Les combats romancés entre
avions de chasse des Chevaliers du Ciel,
avec les forces
du légendaire Baron Rouge von Richthofen
sont plus un spectacle
pour l'infanterie lasse et harassé au sol
qu'ils n'ont
d'influence sur le cours de la guerre.
Même les gigantesques zeppelins,
plus grande menace à leur équipages
qu'à leurs cibles, sont observés
et jugés comme une invention extravagante
par un public ébahi.
L'avion n'est que
le petit enfant de la guerre.
Tandis que le va et vient
continu sur le front de l'Est
pendant toute l'année 1915,
l'entrée en guerre des Italiens du côté
des alliés au mois de mai
ouvre tout un nouveau front dans le Tyrol
et une nouvelle
forme de stratégie basée sur la maxime
"Qui tient les hauteurs,
tient les vallées."
L'attaque éventuelle de
l'Allemagne à revers par l'Autriche
est pratiquement interdite par la nature.
La guerre des Alpes en Italie
n'est qu'une répétition
de la campagne de France,
aux conditions encore plus difficiles.
Une série d'attaques ne menant à rien.
L'Italie, ses nombreux soldats,
son peu d'équipements et de lourds canons
devient une affaire
coûteuse pour l'effort de guerre allié.
En septembre 1915, Foxy
Ferdinand de Bulgarie, voisin de la Serbie
s'allie secrètement
avec l'Allemagne et en octobre,
les Britanniques et les Français
débarquent à Salonique, en Grèce neutre.
Cette manœuvre
manquée pour aider la Serbie
doit immobiliser 600 000 hommes,
dans ce que les observateurs allemands
appellent avec sarcasme le plus
grand camp d'internement de la guerre.
La Turquie se révèle aussi comme une
saignée sur les ressources alliées,
réclamant de
plus en plus de troupes impériales
pour les campagnes
de Mésopotamie et des Dardanelles.
Ce qui commence comme
une opération pour sauvegarder
les installations
de pétrole du golfe Persique
se termine par l'humiliation
des Britanniques au siège de Kut
ou ce qu'il en reste.
Un groupe de soldats affamés sous
le commandement de l'ambitieux Townsend
se rend en avril 1916,
aux implacables Turcs.
Les troupes indiennes
émaciées se laissent mourir de faim
plutôt que de manger
de la viande de cheval.
La Turquie, bien qu'un ennemi secondaire
se montre un adversaire redoutable.
À Gallipoli, les forces britanniques,
australiennes, néo-zélandaises
et françaises combinées
sont très mal équipées.
Elles rencontrent
une vive résistance des Turcs
et ne parviennent qu'à prendre
pied précairement sur la péninsule,
au Cap, et à la
crique Anzac, avant que la campagne
ne s'installe dans
l'impasse de tranchée trop familière,
rendue insupportable
par la chaleur extrême, les maladies
et l'insuffisance
critique d'approvisionnement.
La puissance maritime britannique
tant vantée fait gravement défaut
alors que la guerre est acculée
dans une nouvelle impasse.
Au début de l'année 1916,
les dernières troupes sont évacuées
de Gallipoli, un repli tactique brillant
terminant la tragédie des Dardanelles.
Fausse manœuvre
terrible, bien que magnifique.
Une action décisive aurait pu
forcer la Turquie à sortir de la guerre.
La route commerciale
vers la Russie aurait été dégagée
et un nouveau front
aurait été ouvert contre l'Allemagne.
Mais le détroit
de la mer Noire reste bloqué
et la Russie isolée
de ses alliés de l'Ouest.
Les survivants
de Gallipoli laissent derrière eux
200 000 camarades disparus,
victimes de la maladie comme du conflit.
L'architecte du fiasco, Winston Churchill,
ne regagne pas sa réputation
pendant toute la durée de la guerre.
Pourtant, le grand carnage
ne s'est pas encore produit.
La guerre s'aggrave,
envahissant tous les secteurs
de la vie
économique, politique et sociale.
La guerre devient
dangereuse pour l'élite dirigeante
dont la mauvaise gestion
et la faiblesse sautent aux yeux.
Maintenant, ils ne
peuvent se permettre une défaite.
La guerre est poursuivie
avec une férocité encore plus grande
quand le front réclame
de plus en plus d'hommes, d'obus,
et d'armes
pour sortir de l'impasse sanglante.
L'enjeu est considérable.
Les disparus ne peuvent
avoir à affronter la mort en vain.
De cette campagne
résolue sur le front de l'Ouest,
trois batailles qui deviennent
le symbole de la Première Guerre mondiale,
du carnage effrayant,
des opérations qui ne mènent à rien.
Verdun, la Somme et Passchendaele.
La facilité des Allemands à transporter
leur armée d'un front à l'autre,
d'un lieu critique à l'autre,
grâce à leur
réseau ferroviaire stratégique,
amène les Alliés
à lancer un assaut total en 1916
et à appliquer une pression concentrique
militaire, navale et économique
pour écraser les puissances
d'Europe centrale une fois pour toutes.
Le pivot de la stratégie
doit être une attaque massive
où les lignes alliées
se rencontrent à la Somme.
Mais l'Allemagne a son propre plan.
Un assaut sur une cible,
symbole cher aux Français
qu'ils doivent défendre jusqu'au bout.
Les forteresses de Verdun.
À sept heures du matin le 21 février 1916,
les Allemands
commencent la grande bataille
avec le bombardement le plus
destructif jamais vu dans cette guerre.
Cependant, dix mois
plus tard, Verdun résiste toujours.
Grâce à la ténacité
des Français, à la voie sacrée,
l'artère vitale
par laquelle 3000 camions par jour
apportent des vivres à l'armée
assiégée, Verdun est toujours en vie.
Mais à quel prix ?
Le grand creusé de
destruction a fait 700 000 victimes
parmi les Français, les Allemands,
et tout cela pour
quelques futiles forteresses.
Et la folie continue.
Avec le siège de Verdun,
la Somme a perdu toute valeur
stratégique en tant que champ de bataille.
Cependant, avec une
obstination classique, les Britanniques
décident de mettre leur plan à
exécution contre un ennemi bien préparé.
Fort d'un système de tranchées,
abri de douze mètres de profondeur,
bien protégé
contre le plus fort bombardement.
Il est inconcevable
que cette ligne puisse être forcée.
Cependant, le 1ᵉʳ juillet, après huit
jours de tirs de barrage sans effet,
la quatrième armée britannique
monte au front en ordre parfait.
Vague après vague les troupes d'infanterie
quittent leurs tranchées
un matin de juillet ensoleillé
pour aller s'empêtrer
avec un équipement lourd
dans les fils de fer enchevêtrés
et s'embourber dans les cratères
et les fondrières
creusées par le bombardement.
Les Allemands ont le
temps de sortir indemne de leur tranchée
et de commencer
un carnage horriblement facile.
Avec la dernière salve de mitrailleuse,
les canons deviennent
silencieux sur la Somme.
À la fin de l'après-midi,
les Britanniques perdent 60 000 soldats,
dont un tiers sont tués
au cours de la pire journée de carnage
infligée par
une armée pendant la guerre.
Le jour le plus sanglant
dans l'histoire de l'armée britannique.
Trois jours
s'écoulent avant que les blessés
puissent être ramenés dans des
douleurs intenses du champ de tuerie.
Pourtant, pendant
six mois encore, le bain de sang continue,
avec une indifférence
presque criminelle de la part des généraux
qui refusent de renoncer
à leur vantardise ou changer
quoi que ce soit
à la rigueur de leur plan.
C'est la guerre selon les règles,
une tentative de contrôle des incertitudes
et des confusions de la guerre
en refusant simplement de les reconnaître.
Au 13 novembre,
la vanité obstinée des deux camps cause
un million de morts et de blessés.
Les infortunés
guerriers de la Somme, épuisés,
doivent être les
témoins de deux événements
qui deviennent le symbole
d'une guerre qui a changé pour toujours.
Le 14 juillet, dans une soudaine
attaque matinale du front allemand,
les lignes sont
occupées sur huit kilomètres.
Puis survient
cette échappée traditionnelle
dont rêve tout général britannique.
L'infanterie est témoin d'un
spectacle unique sur le front de l'Ouest.
Trois divisions de
cavalerie galopant vers la brèche,
au son du clairon, les fanions
au vent, les lances étincelantes.
La vision glorieuse s'écroule alors
que les mitrailleuses ouvrent le feu.
Deux mois plus tard, les
premiers rares chars d'assaut britannique
écrasent les fils de fer barbelés.
L'idéalisme périt sur la Somme.
Les volontaires
enthousiaste ne le sont plus.
Ils perdent la foi en leur
cause, en leurs chefs et en tout,
excepté la loyauté envers leurs camarades.
Les populations civiles
sentent la guerre se rapprocher.
Parmi les victimes
se trouvent non pas des héros lointains,
mais leurs amis,
leurs parents, leurs proches.
L'inflation apparaît,
le prix de la nourriture monte en flèche.
Les prix ne sont soumis à aucun contrôle.
Les files pour le pain
et les soupes populaires se multiplient.
Le marché noir fait rage.
L'Allemagne, victime
d'une moisson ratée et commençant
à ressentir
l'effet du blocus, meurt de faim.
Malgré les privations d'un nombre
toujours plus grand de la population,
en Grande-Bretagne, les riches peuvent
toujours se permettre des divertissements.
Fermant une aile de leur
demeure pour économiser le combustible,
ou perdant des domestiques allant
travailler dans les usines de munitions.
Il y a toujours Ascot et le derby, même
si la gaieté de Paris leur est interdite.
Cependant, face à
l'inégalité flagrante, dans tous les pays,
des fissures commencent à apparaître.
La trêve sociale chancelante en 1914,
a simplement camouflé les lézardes
provoquées par l'hostilité
entre l'élite dirigeante
et le peuple
exigeant des réformes sociales.
On ne voit encore
que des signes sporadiques
émeutes de la faim,
grèves contre la conscription,
groupes de pression,
de conscience devenant plus puissants.
Le grondement
des mécontents se fait plus bruyant.
Les troubles nationalistes
alimentent ce feu caché.
La révolte arabe contre l'Empire ottoman,
le soulèvement de Pâques
manquée des séparatistes irlandais,
les désertions tchèques dans
les armées austro-hongroise polyglottes
qui sont déjà affaiblis par l'offensive
d'été du général russe Brussilow
en 1916.
Cette offensive a des conséquences
politiques d'une portée considérable.
Les armées des Habsbourg
perdent leur enthousiasme pour la lutte.
L'unité, la loyauté
et la cohésion disparaissent.
La perte d'un million de soldats au cours
de cette campagne russe de la guerre,
contribue à l'effondrement
de la dynastie des Romanov,
dégageant la voie
pour la révolution de 1917.
Alors qu'on assiste
à la débandade des Russes
et leur abandon
de la guerre en signe de mécontentement.
En novembre 1916,
le vieil empereur au destin tragique,
François-Joseph d'Autriche s'éteint,
signalant la fin d'une époque
comme l'ouvrage de sa vie s'écrouler,
l'empire pour lequel
il a combattu et conspiré,
déchiré par la guerre et l'insurrection.
Avec lui, l'ancienne
Europe disparaît à jamais.
La guerre totale, qui a empiété sur la
vie de chaque citoyen en est la garantie.
Les promesses vaines
de 1914 se sont maintenant changées
en une amère dérision,
alors que la facture du boucher
dénombrant les vies gâchées,
la faim, les privations, les sacrifices
et les chagrins est examinée.
La ferveur nationaliste enflammée
par une propagande trompeuse,
s'est aigrie pour devenir
désillusion, désespoir et amertume
qui se lit sur les visages silencieux et
crispés de ceux qui reviennent du front.
On me demande où je suis
allé, ce que j'ai fait, ce que j'ai vu,
tout ce que je peux répondre,
ce n'était peut-être pas moi,
mais quelqu'un juste comme
moi qui est allé au-delà des mers
avec ma tête et mes mains,
tuer des hommes en terres étrangères,
bien que je sois à blâmer
parce qu'il portait mon nom.
Il n'y aura pas de paix ni de compromis.
La conscription remplit
les vides laissés par les disparus,
les nations combattantes se serrent
la ceinture et remplissent leurs arsenaux
pour une autre année de guerre.
Une guerre d'engins encore plus diabolique
pour mutiler, pour tuer.
Inspiré de la nouvelle technologie humaine
le sous-marin, le char et le plus obscène
et redouté de tous, le gaz asphyxiant.
Contrastée de l'Europe,
l'Amérique qui a mis un point d'honneur
à ne pas faire la guerre jouit de la
période la plus prospère de son histoire
s'enrichissant sur les besoins des alliés.
Tandis que le président Woodrow Wilson
joue le rôle d'artisan de la paix.
Le 18 décembre 1916,
Wilson invite les belligérants
à stipuler leurs conditions de paix.
Mais il est trop tard.
Les dirigeants Lloyd George
en Grande-Bretagne, Nivelles en France
et le puissant Ludendorff
s'opposent formellement à un compromis.
Les Alliés sont alors résolus
à entraîner les États-Unis dans la guerre.
Il ne faut qu'un dernier
rappel à l'idéalisme américain
pour porter
ses vastes ressources du côté des alliés.
Les Yankees arriveront bientôt
et la guerre continuera.
Les soldats se terrent dans les tranchées
et tout le long du front de l'Ouest.
Au cœur de ce troisième hiver glacial,
ils doivent méditer avec tristesse
sur la promesse vaine de 1914.
On leur avait dit alors qu'ils
seraient rentré à la maison pour Noël.
On ne leur avait pas précisé lequel.
Au cours de l'été 1914,
les nations de l'Europe
entrent dans un conflit d'une
sauvagerie imprévisible et sans précédent.
Le mouvement vers
la guerre est inexorable.
Pourtant la guerre aurait pu être évitée.
Le consensus général
et une apparente cordialité
masquent les dissensions qui se préparent,
cachées par une impressionnante logique de
mobilisation industrielle et d'armement.
Du centre de la tempête balkanique,
les vents de la guerre
se déchaînent vers l'extérieur,
engouffrant les nations
les unes après les autres.
Dans un tourbillon de rumeurs,
de menaces et de diplomatie frénétique,
les grandes puissances mobilisent
leurs troupes, en marche vers la guerre.
Pendant 40 ans,
une structure d'alliance
maintient l'équilibre du pouvoir
en Europe et par conséquent la paix.
En 1914, cette structure
se cristallise en deux grands camps armés.
En Europe centrale,
l'Allemagne et l'Autriche-Hongrie
s'allient à la Turquie.
À la périphérie,
la Grande-Bretagne, la France et la Russie
font le contrepoids.
Depuis la guerre franco prussienne
de 1871,
les chefs militaires,
les progressistes comme les réactionnaires
se mettent d'accord sur un point.
La suprématie de l'attaque
est la meilleure méthode de défense.
La mobilisation des Russes à
l'appui de leurs intérêts dans les Balkans
provoque une peur panique
parmi les puissances d'Europe centrale.
Craignant une guerre
sur deux fronts les Allemands élaborent
une stratégie de mobilisation
rapide et d'avance fulgurante
à travers la Belgique,
pour pénétrer en France.
En contournant l'armée française
et en encerclant Paris par l'Ouest,
les Allemands projettent
l'élimination rapide de la France,
toute menace sérieuse
de ce côté est donc écartée.
Un système
d'alliance conçu pour maintenir la paix,
combiné avec des philosophies
militaires en faveur de l'attaque,
pousse l'Europe toujours plus près
pour finalement
la précipiter dans la guerre.
La ferveur guerrière est généralisée.
Chaque nation entre en guerre,
croyant le faire
au titre de la légitime défense.
À la perspective de noble
sacrifice, d'aventure et de gloire,
vient s'ajouter
la conviction d'une vertu morale.
On voit partout des
démonstrations d'unité nationale.
Le patriotisme
est exacerbé par la propagande.
Les conflits se dissipent,
dans un nouvel esprit
de conciliation et de compromis.
Il y a un sentiment universel de vertu,
et une certitude
que tout sera réglé très vite.
En septembre,
après six semaines de combats violents,
la campagne allemande
en France et en Belgique
est en perte de vitesse sur la Marne.
À l'Est les Russes
subissent de lourdes pertes
aux batailles
de Tannenberg et des lacs mazuriens.
En décembre, ils sont sur la défensive
et stabilisent la ligne de front.
En France, la guerre
dégénère en un futile massacre
rendu encore plus terrible
par un bombardement incessant.
Les camps combattent
pour regagner l'initiative
et reprendre la guerre de mouvement.
Face à une impasse en France,
et face à une pause
inquiétante sur le front de l'Est,
les Alliés obtiennent
l'intervention de l'Italie
grâce aux promesses de gains territoriaux
en Autriche et dans les Balkans.
La contribution des
Italiens se montre insuffisante
pour affronter l'Europe centrale
ou pour forcer l'impasse militaire
en retirant des forces des autres fronts.
De nouveaux efforts sont déployés
pour étendre la guerre.
Des débarquements
à Salonique et Dardanelles
n'apportent que des
échecs et une stagnation
plus intense sur tous les fronts.
On essaie de faire porter le fardeau
de la guerre aux populations civiles.
Les flottes
de la Grande-Bretagne et de la France
imposent un blocus
de leurs ennemis continentaux.
Sous les eaux,
les Allemands imposent leur propre blocus.
Les pertes en hommes
sur le front se multiplient
et parallèlement, les privations
s'intensifient dans le pays.
À la pénurie croissante viennent s'ajouter
les exigences insistantes de l'industrie.
Le flot des armes a pour but de
rétablir la guerre de mouvement
mais il produit l'effet contraire.
Sur un terrain défoncé et tourmenté
par les incessants bombardements.
Les troupes qui avancent
sont dans une situation désavantageuse
sur tous les points.
Pourtant, le carnage se poursuit.
Aux batailles
de Verdun et de la Somme en 1916,
près de 2 millions
de vies sont sacrifiées en vain.
Cette stagnation ne renferme guère
d'espoir de solution pacifique.
La guerre qui avait
commencé en une bataille de survie,
développe son propre
dynamisme incontrôlable.
L'apparition en politique de Hindenburg
et de Ludendorff en Allemagne,
de Lloyd George en Grande-Bretagne
et de Clémenceau en France,
marque un durcissement
des attitudes et une impasse politique
aussi absolue
que n'importe quelle impasse militaire.
C'est ainsi qu'en 1917,
les puissances sont toujours en guerre.
Le conflit est rendu
encore plus mortel et plus insoluble
par l'impasse des armes
et le manque d'initiatives.
Sur chaque champ de bataille,
des luttes mornes reflètent la détresse
et l'épuisement total
des hommes et des nations.
Dans les airs,
un sentiment de vigueur
et de mouvement voit le jour.
Au début de la guerre, l'aéroplane en est
encore à ses premiers balbutiements,
les premières machines aux
constructions maladroites et rudimentaires
attirent les critiques plutôt
que les louanges des chefs militaires.
Cependant aux premiers mois de la guerre
ils prouvent leur valeur
et justifient les investissements
qui leur sont accordés de mauvaise grâce.
Les aviateurs britanniques
sont les premiers à faire connaître
les mouvements
des Allemands vers la Marne,
permettant ainsi de prendre
des mesures pour arrêter leur avance.
Les pionniers
de la reconnaissance aérienne
sont munis de pistolets ou de carabines.
Ces armes sont
remplacées par des mitrailleuses
montées à l'arrière de
l'appareil ou en une position
leur permettant de faire feu
à l'avant au-dessus de l'hélice.
C'est en 1915 qu'est
mis au point l'interrupteur mécanique.
Ce dispositif permet
de faire feu à travers l'arc de l'hélice
en déclenchant
la culasse lorsque la balle
se trouve dans la ligne de tir.
Cette invention permet de lancer
le premier appareil de chasse véritable.
Les progrès remarquables de la technologie
des aéroplanes pendant la guerre
et le développement simultané
des tactiques de combat aérien
reflètent un esprit d'initiative
qui fait singulièrement défaut
dans presque tous
les autres théâtres de conflits.
Ayant prouvé leur valeur
dans le domaine de la reconnaissance,
les aviateurs s'assureront par
la suite que les hostilités seront menées
avec autant de
véhémence en l'air que sur Terre,
car le contrôle
du ciel au-dessus des tranchées,
décide du contrôle
des renseignements militaires.
En plus de la reconnaissance,
les aéroplanes servent en plus
au meilleur positionnement des canons,
permettant à l'artillerie de viser les
positions ennemies avec plus de précision.
À partir de ces
débuts primitifs devaient évoluer
les premiers bombardiers
spécialisés et le commencement
de ce qui va devenir une controverse
sans fin entre le bombardement tactique
et le bombardement stratégique.
Les raids de zeppelins sur Londres
engendrent le concept du bombardement
des industries
et des installations loin du front,
mais aussi de toute une population,
ce qui sape le moral
et affaiblit la résolution nationale.
Le rôle en évolution des
aéroplanes conduit à des spécialisations
et des divergences
par la production de différents modèles
destinés à des usages variés.
En 1917, on assiste à la mise au point
des premiers bombardiers à longue portée.
Parmi eux, le remarquable Gotha,
un avion bimoteur à hélice propulsive
qui reprend en grande partie
le rôle du zeppelin en bombardant Londres
par intermittence de
1917 jusqu'à la fin de la guerre.
Le premier avion de
combat fait aussi son apparition,
de même que l'avion de reconnaissance
léger, rapide et plus sophistiqué.
De grands progrès voient le jour
dans les formations spécialisées,
alors que les camps cherchent à résoudre
les problèmes de défense aérienne.
En même temps que les ballons de barrage,
les canons
anti-aériens font leur apparition.
Au début, les canons
de campagne de l'armée
sont munis d'affût à forte déviation,
mais ils sont
accompagnés bientôt d'armes spécialisées
lançant des obus
munis de fusées à retardement.
Pour les soldats dans les tranchées et les
citadins las et de plus en plus accablés,
les exploits de ces premiers
aviateurs représentent le seul soulagement
au milieu de la
stagnation paralysante du front,
les appels de la sirène et les
demandes pour de plus grands sacrifices
et d'efforts au pays.
Survolant les armées qui
se morfondent dans la boue envahissante,
ils tiennent la promesse illusoire
qui a galvanisé les nations
durant l'été de 1914,
la promesse d'aventures,
de nobles combats, d'actions héroïques.
Et pour ces exploits,
ils doivent payer chèrement.
En un mois,
en 1917, sur le front de l'Ouest,
les Britanniques seuls
perdent 316 pilotes et observateurs,
et 224 avions,
à cette époque, presque un
tiers de leur entière force d'opérations.
Parmi les rôles
des aviateurs dans la Grande Guerre,
l'un surtout, acquiert
une fascination et un prestige
au-dessus de tous les
autres, celui de pilote d'attaque.
On appellera d'ailleurs
les plus valeureux des as.
Parmi eux des noms destinés à figurer pour
toujours dans les annales de la guerre.
Manfred von Richthofen, le baron rouge,
major Mike Mannock du Royal Flying Corps,
le pilote d'attaque
et as canadien Billy Bishop,
et un autre qui doit mettre sa réputation
au service de l'infamie d'une autre guerre
l'as allemand Hermann Goering.
En 1917, l'aviation
et tout ce qui s'y rapporte
enflamme l'imagination du monde entier.
Les progrès
dans d'autres domaines sont plus lents
et souvent l'objet d'intrigues politiques.
Mais une de
ces innovations est déjà testée
et mise à l'épreuve
à la bataille de la Somme en 1916.
Bien que rejeté comme une
absurdité lors de sa première apparition,
en 1917, le char de combat est reconnu
comme une formidable arme de guerre.
La seule arme en fait,
qui semble capable de faire évoluer
la situation sur le front.
En Grande-Bretagne et en France,
différents modèles sont mis au point
et testés dans
un climat de ferveur et d'impatience.
Les doctrines tactiques,
longtemps figées, sont enfin confrontées
à la dure réalité de la guerre moderne.
Cependant, tandis que
ces machines offrent la possibilité
de sortir de l'impasse
sur le front, elles contribuent aussi
à l'industrialisation
grandissante de la guerre.
Combat tout aussi crucial
malgré son éloignement géographique
du champ de bataille.
On reconnaît que le sort de la guerre
sera finalement décidé
non pas par les forces des armées,
mais par l'exploitation et l'application
des ressources de l'industrie
à la production des armes de guerre.
Le nombre de soldats n'est
plus considéré aussi important
que le nombre de
chars de canon et d'aéroplane.
Au cours des
premiers mois de l'année 1917,
les populations de
l'Allemagne et Autriche-Hongrie
sont soumises à d'immenses souffrances.
De maigres moissons
en 1915 et 1916, et le blocus des Alliés
contribuent à la
misère d'un hiver rigoureux
où la faim et la malnutrition
des citoyens contrastent lugubrement
avec d'autres
pays avec la richesse évidente
des profiteurs de la guerre.
L'aggravation de
la pénurie dans chaque pays
entraîne l'apparition du
marché noir et donc à des inégalités
encore plus grandes.
Un sentiment
d'impuissance et de ressentiment.
Les industriels aussi
retirent des bénéfices énormes
de l'insatiable demande d'armes.
Partout le fardeau tombe infailliblement
sur les pauvres et les faibles.
Les premières années,
ils n'attaquent
pas au hasard les navires alliés,
mais confrontés à une
pénurie critique et à un blocus plus dur,
le commandement allemand se résout à une
offensive sous-marine de grande envergure.
Le désespoir allemand
est tel qu'ils ne peuvent s'empêcher
d'entraîner indirectement
les États-Unis dans la guerre.
C'est surtout en Russie que
se font sentir les fardeaux de la guerre.
L'industrialisation
est arrivée tard en Russie.
Ces paysans ne sont libérés
de leur servage que depuis 1861.
Dès lors, le pays connaît
de graves troubles sociaux.
La rationalisation
de l'agriculture et l'apparition
d'agriculteurs
indépendants accélèrent l'exode
des paysans déjà
considérable vers les zones urbaines.
Le prolétariat déraciné
et affamé envahit les villes.
C'est dans ces conditions
que les ressources de la Russie
produisent des résultats.
Au début de la guerre,
elle s'industrialise
plus rapidement que tout autre puissance.
De surcroît,
la guerre lui apporte son élan.
Les premières années de la guerre,
la Russie subit
une transformation industrielle inégalée
par son ampleur et son intensité.
Sa production de matériel de guerre
augmente de façon spectaculaire.
Mais ces résultats sont payés cher.
L'inflation monte en flèche.
Le réseau de communication
commence à se désintégrer.
Des stocks de nourriture
s'entassent dans les campagnes
tandis que les citadins ont faim.
Aucune perspective
de victoire ni aucun accord de paix,
ne permet de soulager les privations
subies par les populations civiles.
En 1917, l'économie
russe chancelante est au bord de l'abîme.
Sa population civile,
tout comme son armée,
traumatisée, démoralisée, perplexe.
Le nombre croissant de victimes,
les privations toujours plus dures,
l'impuissance manifeste
du gouvernement, tout se combine
pour attiser le feu de la révolte.
Les grèves et les
manifestations balaient Saint-Pétersbourg.
La dernière semaine du mois de février,
aux manifestants en protestant
contre la pénurie de denrées alimentaires,
se joignent les cosaques mécontents
postés dans la capitale
pour assurer le maintien de l'ordre.
Un soviet des travailleurs et des
représentants des soldats est créé.
Une immense foule se dirige
vers la Douma, assemblée représentative
instituée par le tsar,
mais sans pouvoir réel.
En présence d'une foule aigrie
et potentiellement dangereuse
et en l'absence complète
d'une quelconque autorité,
la Douma réagit en nommant
un gouvernement provisoire.
Trois jours plus tard,
le 2 mars, le tsar abdique,
reconnaissant ainsi le
gouvernement provisoire et la révolution.
Le 6 avril, les États-Unis
déclarent la guerre à l'Allemagne.
L'offensive de grande
envergure des sous-marins allemands
rend leur intervention inévitable.
Le déclenchement de la guerre
délivre l'Amérique de la récession,
entraînant l'essor
de son économie en 1915 et 1916,
alors qu'elle subvient
aux besoins des nations en guerre.
Les premiers succès
des sous-marins allemands sont inattendus,
et mettent brusquement
un frein à cette expansion économique,
menaçant de plonger l'Amérique
dans un marasme encore plus grave.
La sécurité de ses clients, principalement
la Grande-Bretagne et la France,
qui plient sous le poids de dette,
joue un rôle important
dans la décision des États-Unis.
La garantie de leur paiement
dépend finalement de leur victoire.
Cependant,
l'entrée en guerre des États-Unis
n'est pas inspirée simplement
par ces âpres calculs économiques.
La guerre des sous-marins va à
l'encontre des valeurs morales américaines
et la révolution russe,
par sa promesse de démocratie,
permet aux Américains
de considérer le conflit comme une guerre
entre les peuples libres
et les empires autocrates
des puissances de l'Europe centrale.
L'entrée en guerre de
l'Amérique apporte peu de répit immédiat
à la Grande-Bretagne, souffrant
maintenant d'une pénurie chronique
et d'un mécontentement latent.
Les cinq premiers mois
de l'offensive sous-marine allemande,
les pertes en
navires sont très importantes.
Au cours du mois d'avril,
un navire sur quatre qui appareille
ne revient jamais.
La Grande-Bretagne est elle-même menacée
par l'ultime catastrophe,
un sort qu'elle voulait infliger
à l'Allemagne,
la famine qui entraîne la défaite.
En mai, la marine
britannique institue un système d'escorte
pour les convois maritimes assurant
la protection des navires marchands,
tout en abattant ainsi les sous-marins.
Ce système de convoi
brise en fait la force de l'offensive
sous-marine allemande.
La création
d'appareils d'écoute hydrophoniques
et de grenades
sous-marines contribue à faire tourner
la chance du côté des
alliés dans la bataille de l'Atlantique
assurant ainsi une autre année de guerre
sur terre, sur mer et dans les airs.
Le printemps n'apporte que
plus de carnages sur les champs
de bataille de France.
Un nouveau commandant
français, général Nivelle,
promet aux Alliés
une victoire finale complète en 1917.
La grande offensive est lancée le 16 avril
dans la région du Chemin des Dames.
Dès le début, l'attaque est un désastre.
Malgré des succès mineurs
remportés par les Britanniques
à Arras dans l'ouest,
l'attaque principale
s'embourbe devant les positions allemandes
à peine touchées
par un bombardement fourni.
Le soir, Nivelle
n'a avancé que de 500 mètres
au prix de pertes effrayantes.
Le mois suivant, Nivelle
persiste dans son offensive.
Il obtient sa
promotion en promettant la victoire.
Il doit donc absolument tenir sa promesse
pour éviter un désastre personnel.
Au total, l'offensive de
Nivelle coûte à l'armée française
près de 250 000 hommes
et démoralise les troupes,
à tel point que des
mutineries en chaîne risque d'entraîner
l'effondrement
militaire complet de la France.
En mai,
l'offensive finit par s'essouffler.
Comparé aux pertes,
les gains paraissent insignifiants.
Pour l'infanterie
française, il semble que ce sacrifice
ait été entièrement vain.
Le 15 mai, Nivelle est limogé.
Son remplaçant, le général
Pétain doit faire face à l'immense tâche
qui consiste à rétablir l'ordre
et le moral de ses armées épuisées.
L'échec des Français au Chemin des Dames
place la responsabilité
de l'attaque sur les Britanniques,
leur force étant reconstituée et
rééquipée depuis le désastre de la Somme.
Pour alléger le fardeau des Français
et remporter
une victoire purement britannique,
le général Haig décide d'attaquer
dans les Flandres pendant l'été.
La bataille d'Ypres
commence par le barrage d'artillerie
le plus violent de toute la guerre.
Le bombardement durera
deux semaines, sans succès réel,
mais faisant du terrain
une mer debout, presque infranchissable
et livrant tous les avantages
aux Allemands sur la défensive.
L'attaque initiale
se poursuit pendant cinq jours.
Une avance de trois
kilomètres au prix de 32 000 morts.
Les chars derrière les lignes
ne peuvent prendre part à la bataille.
Le sol ne supporte plus leur poids.
Le 6 août, Haig reprend son offensive
et renouvelle
ses attaques en septembre et en octobre.
En novembre, Haig
avance de neuf kilomètres,
capturant la côte de
Passendaele et ce qui reste du village
qui donnera son nom à la bataille.
La prise de Passendaele
coûte la vie à plus de 500 000 hommes
dont un grand nombre périssent noyés.
En Russie, la situation se détériore.
Une lutte intense
oppose le gouvernement provisoire,
création de la Douma,
au Soviet improvisé,
véritable enfant de la Révolution.
La personnalité
remarquable d'Alexandre Kerensky
domine ces deux conseils.
Idéaliste charismatique,
il se résout à consolider
la nouvelle démocratie russe.
Pour cela, Kerensky croit devoir honorer
les engagements de la Russie à l'étranger,
et, en continuant la guerre,
obtenir un accord honorable pour son pays.
Mais selon l'ordre numéro un
du Soviet, le simple soldat russe
ne peut être forcé d'exécuter
les ordres qui sont en contradiction
avec ses désirs personnels.
La discipline
s'effondre complètement sur le front.
Les désertions sont endémiques.
Non pas le filet régulier
de vagabonds en fuite,
mais une marée déferlante qui
s'apparente à une démobilisation complète.
Car d'autres forces
plus insidieuses menacent Kerensky.
Ces événements prennent
les révolutionnaires professionnels russes
par surprise, embarras
qu'ils tiennent absolument à masquer.
À l'époque, le chef des
bolchéviks Lénine, se trouve en Suisse.
Les Allemands prennent
conscience qu'il ignore presque tout
de la crise qui secoue son pays.
Voyant en Lénine l'instrument avec
lequel ils peuvent renverser Kerensky,
mais aussi précipiter la
Russie entière dans la catastrophe,
Ils envoient celui-ci
secrètement en Russie via l'Allemagne.
Des fonds lui parviennent
par leurs agents pour financer sa mission.
La première tentative
de Lénine pour renverser Kerensky échoue.
À la suite d'un coup
d'état manqué en juillet,
Lénine est démasqué comme agent allemand,
et est forcé de fuir Saint-Pétersbourg.
Il se déguise en rasant sa moustache
et endossant les vêtements d'un ouvrier.
Caché en Finlande, Lénine
continue à comploter contre Kerensky,
exhortant ses partisans
à saisir les positions clés dans le Soviet
et ainsi élargir le gouffre existant
entre le Soviet et le gouvernement.
Le conflit opposant
le gouvernement à ce qui reste de l'armée,
à un chaos
économique et industriel grandissant,
affaiblit davantage Kerensky
et renforce la position des bolchéviques,
s'armant alors frénétiquement en prévision
de l'effondrement total du gouvernement.
Le matin du 27 octobre,
tandis que Kerensky essaie
de mobiliser
des partisans dans les campagnes,
le palais d'hiver
est pillé par les bolchéviques
qui proclament
la chute du gouvernement provisoire.
C'est ainsi que la démocratie
est finalement écrasée en Russie.
La victoire des
bolchéviques met fin à la participation
de la Russie à la guerre, participation
devenue plus symbolique que réelle.
La paix de Brest-Litovsk,
signée au début de l'année 1918,
permet à l'Allemagne
de transférer des divisions à l'Ouest
et de rassembler ses forces
pour une dernière grande offensive.
La lutte pour
s'assurer la suprématie aérienne
repose autant sur
la technologie que sur la tactique.
Les progrès remarquables
des premières années de la guerre
acquièrent des
raffinements subtils la dernière année.
Légère amélioration des
structures ou de la puissance du moteur
augmentant la vitesse d'un appareil
ou donnant un avantage à sa performance,
peut lui permettre immédiatement
de surpasser la machine d'un adversaire,
transformant pratiquement
l'aéroplane en une arme mortelle.
Le Sopwith Camel assure
la supériorité des Britanniques en 1917,
mais l'arrivée de
l'incomparable Fokker.7 en 1918,
rend aux Allemands la suprématie aérienne.
Assuré de la maîtrise
du ciel au-dessus des tranchées,
les allemands peuvent constituer
en secret une armée de 3 millions d'hommes
et de 10 000 canons.
Le plan de Ludendorff est
de déclencher une offensive fulgurante
le long d'un front de 60 kilomètres.
Le but est d'écraser
les armées britanniques sur la Somme,
déséquilibrer le front allié
et repousser la ligne d'est en ouest.
L'offensive débute
à l'aube du 21 mars 1918.
Après un
bombardement bref mais destructeur,
les Allemands avancent
protégés par un nuage épais
de brouillard matinal.
Cette fois ce n'est pas
un déploiement d'infanterie en masse
mais de troupes de choc
spécialement entraînés pour cerner
les faiblesses des lignes britanniques.
Des équipes de combat les suivent
dans le but
d'ouvrir des brèches à l'armée qui arrive.
Ces tactiques sont complètement nouvelles.
Tactique d'avance
éclair et d'encerclement rapide.
Elles seraient connues plus
tard sous le nom de tactique Blitzkrieg.
En 1918, elles sont dévastatrices.
À la tombée de la nuit,
les allemands s'enfoncent dans
l'arrière garde de la zone britannique
et en l'espace de quelques jours,
poursuivent
leur marche en pleine campagne.
Des milliers
de soldats britanniques sont dépassés.
Il semble à bien des gens que
la guerre est sur le point de se terminer.
Les lignes
britanniques sur la Somme sont enfoncées
et leurs armées menacées de disparition.
Les Français
se préparent à se replier sur Paris.
Au dernier moment, le désastre est évité,
non pas par un miracle militaire,
mais en plaçant les britanniques
au commandement du maréchal Foch,
l'unifiant ainsi, engageant les
Français à appuyer l'armée britannique.
Au début du mois d'avril, l'avancée claire
des Allemands commence à s'affaiblir.
Pratiquement en déroute,
les Britanniques et les Français
ont recours
à leurs réserves mobilisées à la hâte.
Par contre, les Allemands
sont sur le point d'épuiser les leurs.
Durant quatre jours,
ils arrêtent leur offensive
pour se rééquiper et se réapprovisionner.
Les deux camps savent que la guerre
entre maintenant dans une phase décisive.
Les troupes américaines
arrivent enfin en nombre suffisant
pour faire pencher la balance.
Si les alliés
peuvent braver l'orage allemand,
la guerre sera finalement gagnée.
Le 9 avril, la tempête
se déchaîne de nouveau
sur la deuxième
armée britannique dans l'avancée d'Ypres.
De nouveau, les Allemands envahissent
la zone de bataille britannique,
progressant en
certains endroits de 20 kilomètres.
Comme à la bataille de la Somme,
les Britanniques réussissent à stabiliser
le front en se retirant en temps opportun
et en rassemblant tous les effectifs
possibles pour combler les brèches.
Repoussés au centre et à l'ouest du front,
l'attaque se détourne vers les lignes
françaises le long du Chemin des Dames.
Le 3 juin,
les Allemands déferlent sur ces lieux.
Ils avancent impitoyablement
de 60 kilomètres vers la Marne.
Là, les Allemands reçoivent sans ambages
leur premier
avertissement sur ce qui les attend.
La route de Paris est bloquée non pas
par les Français, mais par les Américains.
À la tête
du commandement des armées alliées,
Foch maintient
d'imposantes réserves stratégiques.
Elles servent à retenir les Allemands
au point le plus éloignés de leur avance.
Pendant tout le
mois de juillet, le front résiste
et la menace
sur Paris est contenue sur la Marne.
En août, les Britanniques et les Français
qui luttent à leurs côtés,
lancent la contre-attaque à Amiens.
Jusqu'ici, les chars
n'ont jamais été employés avec succès
depuis les batailles de la Somme en 1916,
où les chars
se sont lamentablement embourbés,
leurs immenses avantages ont été
gaspillés par une incompétence tactique
et une réticence obstinée
à les traiter autrement que comme
des équipements superflus et coûteux.
À Amiens, sur un sol ferme d'été,
les chars avancent pour la première fois
avec l'appui conjugué de l'infanterie.
Pour une fois,
ils ne sont pas annoncés par l'habituel
martèlement interminable des canons,
ces mastodontes métalliques
trapus, roulent hors des brumes de l'aube,
au-dessus des
fils de fer barbelés et des tranchées,
justifiant tous les efforts et toutes
les dépenses qui leur ont été consacrées.
Dans la soirée, les chars sont à
onze kilomètres de leur ligne de départ.
15 000 Allemands sont faits prisonniers
et bien davantage tués ou blessés.
Pourtant, le 8 août 1918 est bien
plus qu'une victoire pour le bon sens.
Ludendorff l'appellera
le jour sombre des armées allemandes,
le jour où l'Allemagne perd la guerre.
Si les implications de la défaite d'Amiens
sont comprises du haut commandement,
elles sont loin
de l'être pour l'infanterie allemande,
dont la patience est mise à rude épreuve.
Sur chaque champ de bataille,
ils occupent encore un sol étranger,
le front de l'ouest
se trouve plus près de Paris
qu'à aucun autre moment depuis 1914.
Le flux continu
des troupes et des armes américaines
assure que Paris restera pour toujours
au-delà de la portée de l'Allemagne.
Alors qu'aux flottes
de la Grande-Bretagne et de la France
s'ajoutent l'Amérique,
transformant le blocus
en étau d'acier toujours plus resserré.
Après quatre ans
de blocus et de sacrifices immenses,
les puissances de l'Europe centrale sont
proches de la famine et de l'effondrement.
La capitulation
de la Bulgarie en septembre 1918
apporte encore
plus d'isolation et de privations.
Des bruits courent
que la défaite est proche.
La demande d'un
armistice le 4 octobre a pour résultat
d'attiser
le mécontentement de l'opinion publique
et de démoraliser
encore plus les armées sur le front.
Face à la puissance
militaire des alliés sur terre,
en mer et dans les airs,
les alliés de l'Allemagne vacillent
puis s'écroulent.
L'effondrement interne
de l'Autriche-Hongrie en octobre,
et sa capitulation le 2 novembre,
laisse l'étau d'acier se refermer
sur une Allemagne totalement isolée.
En Allemagne,
les négociations s'éternisent
avec en toile de fond des intrigues
politiques et des troubles civils.
Des initiatives
symboliques et sans substance
sont lancées
en faveur de la démocratie parlementaire.
Ludendorff est révoqué.
Le 3 novembre une mutinerie
navale se répand dans les rues de Kiel.
Le lendemain soir Kiel est
entre les mains d'un conseil de marins.
La révolte se propage à
Hambourg, Brême, Wilhelmshaven, Cologne.
La révolution infligée à
la Russie par des complots allemands
menace à présent l'Allemagne elle-même.
Le 9 novembre,
des manifestations et des grèves
éclatent à Berlin.
Le Reichstag
annonce l'abdication du Kaiser
et l'établissement
d'une république allemande.
Le dirigeant social
démocrate Friedrich Ebert
est nommé chancelier.
L'affolement, la confusion
et le spectre d'une révolution sanglante
s'emparent de l'Allemagne.
Plus rien n'importe maintenant
que le rapatriement des soldats.
Parmi eux, on trouve
toujours des hommes fidèles à la patrie,
toujours prêts à la servir lorsqu'elle
connaît les plus grands dangers.
Le 10 novembre,
les dirigeants de l'Allemagne acceptent,
sans autre forme de procès,
les conditions présentées par les Alliés.
Le jour suivant, le 11 novembre 1918,
la Grande Guerre prend fin.
L'Allemagne n'a
guère de raisons de se réjouir.
L'Armistice que ses
représentants ont signé ressemble
à une capitulation sans conditions.
L'évacuation immédiate
de la France et de la Belgique
correspond à ses pressants
besoins de rétablir l'ordre dans le pays.
Elle doit aussi accepter
de livrer à l'occupation étrangère
de vastes régions de
la Rhénanie et céder d'immenses quantités
d'équipements de guerre,
y compris une grande
partie de son aviation et de sa flotte.
De telles concessions ternissent
l'image de la nouvelle République
aux yeux de ses héritiers.
En 1919, l'Allemagne est toujours en proie
à la faim, au chaos et à la guerre civile.
Pour s'assurer
que leurs conditions sont respectées,
les alliées
maintiennent leur blocus naval
durant le printemps et l'été,
transformant les privations en temps
de guerre, en famine, de temps de paix.
Parmi les troupes démobilisés,
la République trouve les hommes
pour chasser le spectre de la révolution
et ramener l'ordre dans la patrie.
On les nomme
le Freikorps, une milice volontaire
d'anciens combattants.
Leur emblème est un macaron porte-bonheur,
souvenir des années de
guerre, appelée la croix gammée.
Les puissances
victorieuses se réunissent à Versailles
pour décider des conditions de la paix.
Il est convenu qu'une telle guerre
ne doit jamais se reproduire
et que des mesures doivent être prises
pour assurer une paix durable en Europe.
L'Allemagne doit
être punie, ses forces armées
réduites à un niveau à peine suffisant
pour maintenir l'ordre en temps de paix.
Les vainqueurs
doivent se partager ses colonies
et certaines parties
de son territoire national.
Il reste la question des réparations,
des dédommagements
pour les dégâts matériels causés.
Ces questions sont importantes
pour les négociateurs de Versailles.
Pour l'Allemagne, il n'y aura
que blâmes, confiscations et humiliations.
Pour la jeune République,
un traité de paix qui la brisera,
ce faisant,
condamne le monde à une autre guerre.